달러 패권은 아직 끝나지 않았습니다.
그런데 미국 국채의 프리미엄은 예전과 다릅니다.
많은 사람들은 달러와 미국 국채를 비슷한 안전자산으로 생각합니다.
위기가 오면 달러가 강해지고 미국 국채도 가장 먼저 찾는 자산이라고 보죠.
그래서 둘은 사실상 한 세트처럼 받아들여져 왔습니다.
그런데 최근 시장을 보면 이 둘은 더 이상 같은 방향으로 움직이지 않습니다.
자, 미리 말씀드리는데 달러는 여전히 특별합니다.
반면 미국 국채는 다른 선진국 국채와 비교하면 예전만큼 특별하지 않습니다.
이게 왜 중요하냐면 우리는 오랫동안 달러의 힘과 미국 국채의 힘을
거의 같은 이야기처럼 받아들여 왔기 때문입니다.
하지만 지금 시장은 그 둘을 따로 가격에 반영하고 있습니다.
달러가 강하다고 해서 미국 국채까지 같은 방식으로 대우받는 것은 아니라는 뜻입니다.
오늘은 왜 이런 일이 벌어졌는지, 최근 데이터는 정확히 무엇을 보여주는지
그리고 미국 국채의 힘과 미국 국채의 힘을 같은 방식으로 대우받는 것은 아니라는 뜻입니다.
이 변화가 앞으로 시장을 볼 때 왜 중요한지를 정리해드리겠습니다.
먼저 아주 짧게 핵심만 잡고 가겠습니다.
달러는 세계에서 가장 많이 쓰는 돈이고 미국 국채는 미국 정부가 발행하는 채권입니다.
오랫동안 세계에서 가장 안전하고 가장 유동적인 국채로 받아들여져 왔죠.
그리고 오늘 계속 보게 될 핵심 개념은 하나입니다.
보유프리미엄입니다.
이건 단순히 가격이 비싸다는 뜻이 아닙니다.
수익률을 조금 덜 받더라도 사람들이 굳이 들고 싶어하는 힘입니다.
안전하고 유동적이고 담보로 쓰기 좋고 위기 때 잘 팔릴 것 같으면 이런 프리미엄이 붙습니다.
그리고 오늘의 비교 대상은 신흥국 채권이 아닙니다.
독일, 영국, 일본, 스위스 같은 주요 선진국 국채입니다.
즉 미국 국채가 위험해졌다는 이야기가 아니라
주요 선진국 국채와 비교했을 때 미국 국채가 받던 추가 점수가 줄어들었다는 이야기를 하려고 하는 겁니다.
이 기본 틀을 잡아놓고 나면 바로 다음 질문이 나옵니다.
지금 우리가 보는 변화가 정말이랍니다.
시장의 변화인지 아니면 단순히 계산 기준이 바뀌어서 그렇게 보이는 건지 확인해야 한다는 겁니다.
왜 이런 의문이 나오냐면 최근 몇 년 사이 글로벌 금융시장의 기준금리 체계가 크게 바뀌었기 때문이죠.
예전에는 리보를 많이 썼고 지금은 소파 같은 새로운 기준으로 넘어왔습니다.
그러면 당연히 이런 질문이 생깁니다.
기준이 바뀌었으니까 숫자도 달리 보이는 것 아닌가 충분히 나올 수 있는 의문입니다.
그런데 데이터를 보면 그렇게 보기 어렵습니다.
달러 쪽 프리미엄은 기준이 바뀐 뒤에도요.
사라지지 않았습니다.
오히려 더 크게 나타난 구간도 있었죠.
반면 미국 국채를 다른 선진국 국채와 비교한 흐름은 기준전환 전후에 큰 방향이 달라지지 않았습니다.
이게 뜻하는 바는 분명합니다.
지금 우리가 보고 있는 건 단순한 계산 방식의 착시가 아니라
시장이 달러와 미국 국채를 실제로 다르게 보기 시작한 변화에 더 가깝다는 겁니다.
그럼 이제 그 변화가 실제로 얼마나 컸는지 긴 흐름부터 보겠습니다.
5년 물 기준으로 미국 국채의 상대평가가
미국 국채의 상대평가가 어떻게 바뀌었는지를 보면
2000년대에는 꽤 높은 수준이었던 구간이 있습니다.
그런데 글로벌 금융위기 이후 흐름이 달라집니다.
2012년쯤부터 주요 선진국 평균이 0 아래로 내려가고
그 뒤로 회복하지 못한 채 더 약해집니다.
숫자로 보면 더 분명합니다.
주요 선진국 기준 5년 물 미국 국채 상대평가는
2012년부터 2020년까지 대략 마이너스 7BP 수준이었는데
2021년부터 2025년까지는 마이너스 7BP 수준이었습니다.
2021년부터 2025년까지는 마이너스 7BP 수준이었는데
마이너스 26BP 안팎으로 더 내려갑니다.
이건 무슨 뜻일까요?
독일이나 영국, 일본 같은 나라의 국채를 달러로 환해지에서 비교했을 때
미국 국채가 예전처럼 더 낮은 수익률을 정당화하지 못하고 있다는 뜻입니다.
시장 가격이 그렇게 바뀌고 있다는 얘기죠.
더 눈에 띄는 건 이 변화가 장기 국채에서만 보이는 게 아니라는 점입니다.
최근 구간을 더 짧게 끊어서 보면 단기 쪽도 흔들립니다.
2023년 이후에는 3개월 물 중앙값이
약 마이너스 7BP, 1년 물 중앙값이 약 마이너스 16BP입니다.
예전에는 중장기에서만 눈에 띄던 변화가
이제는 단기 구간까지 내려온 겁니다.
그런데 여기서 미국 국채의 변화만 따로 보고 있으면
아직 전체 그림이 다 보이지 않습니다.
진짜 핵심은 이 흐름을 달러와 나란히 놓고 볼 때 드러납니다.
달러 프리미엄은 금융위기 이후 꾸준히 플러스권에 남아있습니다.
특히 2021년부터 2025년 평균을 보면
10년 물 달러 프리미엄은
10년 물 달러 프리미엄은 10년 물 달러 프리미엄은
플러스 19BP, 5년 물도 플러스 20BP 안팎입니다.
그런데 같은 기간 미국 국채의 상대 프리미엄은
10년 물이 마이너스 26BP, 5년 물이 마이너스 25BP입니다.
같은 미국 자산인데 한쪽은 플러스이고
다른 한쪽은 마이너스라는 뜻입니다.
이건 결코 작은 차이가 아닙니다.
많은 사람들은 달러와 미국 국채를 거의 같은 의미로 쓰지만
시장 가격은 이미 둘을 다르게 평가하고 있습니다.
여기까지 보면 평소에
흐름은 충분히 확인이 됐습니다.
그런데 안전자산의 진짜 성격은
평소보다 위기 때 더 잘 드러납니다.
그래서 이제는 시장이 흔들릴 때
둘이 어떻게 반응했는지를 봐야 합니다.
여기서 자주 쓰는 지표가 빅스입니다.
쉽게 말해서 시장의 불안정도를 보여주는
대표 지표라고 보시면 됩니다.
이 빅스가 올라갈 때 무엇이 같이 움직였는지를 보면
달러와 미국 국채의 차이가 더 분명해지겠죠.
달러는 최근에도 비교적 일관된 반응을 보입니다.
시장이 불안해질수록
달러 가치가 강해지고
달러를 직접 보유하려는 쪽의 프리미엄도 올라갑니다.
이건 아직 크게 바뀌지 않았습니다.
그런데 미국 국채의 상대 프리미엄은
최근 들어 방향이 달라집니다.
한때는 위기 때 같이 강해졌는데
2020년대에 들어서면서
오히려 흠수 쪽으로 내려가는 구간이 뚜렷해집니다.
특히 1년, 5년, 10년 같은 구간에서 더 그렇습니다.
이 변화는 사건별로 보면 더 직관적입니다.
2008년 리버스에서
2020년 리먼 사태 때는 달러도 강했고 미국 국채도 강했습니다.
그 시기에는 많은 사람이 생각하는 전통적인 그림이 맞았습니다.
위기가 오면 달러도 찾고 미국 국채도 찾았습니다.
그런데 2020년 코로나 충격 때는 모습이 달라집니다.
달러 쪽 프리미엄은 올라가는데
미국 국채의 상대 프리미엄은 중장기에서 약해집니다.
그리고 2025년 4월 상호관세 충격에서도 비슷한 장면이 나옵니다.
달러 프리미엄은 다시 올라갑니다.
그런데 미국 국채의 상대 프리미엄은
5년, 10년에서 더 내려갑니다.
이건 그냥 시장이 잠깐 흔들렸다는 얘기가 아닙니다.
위기 국면에서 조차 달러와 미국 국채가 예전처럼
한몸으로 움직이지 않는다는 뜻입니다.
그래서 이제는 달러가 강하면 미국 국채도 당연히 제일 강하겠지
라고 말하기가 점점 어려워지는 겁니다.
그렇다면 이제 남는 질문은 자연스럽게 하나로 좁혀집니다.
왜 이런 분리가 생겼는가입니다.
핵심은 간단합니다.
달러와 미국 국채는 같은 자산이 아니기 때문입니다.
달러는 세계 결제와 자금 조달의 중심입니다.
해외 금융기관과 투자자들이 달러를 구해야 하는 순간은 계속 생깁니다.
그래서 금융시장이 불안해질수록 달러에 별도의 프리미엄이 붙습니다.
달러의 특별함은 여기서 나오는 겁니다.
반면 미국 국채는 채권입니다.
그리고 채권은 결국 공급의 영향을 크게 받습니다.
여기서 중요한 변화가 하나 있습니다.
미국 국채 발행이 많이 늘어났다는 점입니다.
많이 발행되면 희소성이 약해집니다.
희소성이 약해지면
예전처럼 낮은 수익률로도 무조건 들고 싶어지는 힘이 줄어듭니다.
이 차이가 금리 차이에도 그대로 나타납니다.
같은 2021년부터 2025년 평균을 보면
미국 쪽 수압 스프레드는 10년물에서 마이너스 26BP 수준까지 내려갑니다.
5년물도 마이너스 20BP 수준입니다.
반면 해외 쪽은 10년물은 플러스 18.6BP, 5년물은 플러스 24.9BP로 여전히 플러스입니다.
여기서 수압 스프레드라는 말이 조금 낯설 수 있습니다.
쉽게 말하면 미국 국채가 달러 기준 자산과 비교해서 시장에서 얼마나 특별하게 대우받는 지를 보여주는 금리 차이입니다.
이 차이가 미국에서는 크게 약해졌고 그 결과 달러 프리미엄과 미국 국채 프리미엄이 갈라진 겁니다.
이제 여기서 한 번 더 확인해 볼 필요가 있습니다.
정말 공급이 이렇게 중요한 원인이라면 숫자에서도 같은 방향이 나와야겠죠.
실제 미국 국채는 많이 발행될수록 상대적 프리미엄이 실제로 낮아집니다.
미국의 부채 대비 GDP가 낮아질 수 있습니다.
미국 국채 대비 비율이 1% 늘어날 때 5년물 기준 미국 국채의 상대 프리미엄은 대체로 0.37BP에서 0.86BP 정도로 낮아집니다.
이게 작아 보여도 채권 시장에서는 의미 있는 변화입니다.
그리고 만기별로 미국 국채 공급이 1% 늘어날 때도 해당 만기의 상대 프리미엄이 0.26BP에서 0.28BP 정도 내려갑니다.
반대로 해외 정부채 공급이 늘어나면 미국 국채의 상대 프리미엄은 조금 회복됩니다.
왜냐하면
미국 국채의 상대 프리미엄은 0.26BP에서 0.28BP 정도로 내려갑니다.
하지만 비교 대상이 되는 다른 나라 국채 쪽 기속성도 약해지기 때문입니다.
이 의름은 2025년의 특정 사건에서도 비슷하게 확인됩니다.
4월 2일 상호관세 발표 직후를 보면 부채 비율이 상대적으로 낮은 나라와 비교할수록 미국 국채의 10년물 상대 프리미엄이 더 크게 내려갑니다.
호주, 유럽권, 스웨덴 같은 나라 쪽에서 그 폭이 더 컸고 영국과 일본처럼 부채가 많은 쪽에서는 변화가 상대적으로 작았습니다.
이 장면은 꽤 중요한 힌트를 주죠.
이제 미국 국채의 매력은 미국만 봐서는 안되고 비교 대상이 되는 다른 선진국 국채가 얼마나 희소한지도 같이 봐야 한다는 겁니다.
결국 여기서 보이는 흐름은 명확합니다.
미국 국채의 상대적 특별함은 미국의 막강한 위상 하나만으로 결정되지 않습니다.
얼마나 많이 발행되고 있는지 다른 선진국 국채와 비교했을 때 얼마나 희소한지 이런 아주 현실적인 공급 조건이 함께 움직입니다.
이제 마지막으로 남은 건 이 변화의 의미입니다.
이걸 단순히 채권 시장 안의 숫자 변화로만 보면 핵심을 놓치게 됩니다.
첫째, 달러 패권이 살아있다는 사실만으로 미국이 앞으로도 예전처럼 낮은 비용으로 계속 빚을 낼 수 있다고 단정하기 어려워졌습니다.
달러의 힘과 미국 국채의 조달 프리미엄은 이제 같은 말이 아니기 때문입니다.
둘째, 투자자 입장에서도 달러와 미국 국채를 무조건 같은 안전자산으로 묶으면 해석이 틀어질 수 있습니다.
환율은 달러 강세인데 장기 미국 국채는요.
미국 국채는 상대적으로 더 약해질 수 있습니다.
이 차이를 구분해서 봐야 이제 시장이 읽힙니다.
셋째, 미국 장기 금리를 볼 때 재정과 국채 공급을 훨씬 더 자세히 봐야 합니다.
예전에는 미국 국채는 원래 특별하니까 라는 말이 통했다면 이제는 그 말만으로는 설명이 안됩니다.
얼마나 발행되는지 어떤 만기에 공급이 몰리는지 다른 선진국 국채 공급은 어떤지까지 같이 봐야 하는 겁니다.
이 말이 미국 국채가 끝났다는 얘기가 아닙니다.
그리고 미국 국채가 안전자산이 아니라는 얘기도 아닙니다.
제가 말하고 싶은 건 미국 국채가 다른 주요 선진국 국채와 비교했을 때 누리던 추가 프리미엄이 예전만큼 크지 않다.
바로 그 변화가 지금 시장에 반영되고 있다는 뜻입니다.
정리하겠습니다.
달러는 아직 세계 금융시장에서 가장 중요한 돈입니다.
그래서 불안이 커질수록 달러를 찾는 힘은 여전히 강합니다.
하지만 미국 국채는 다른 선진국 국채가 안전자산이 아니라는 얘기도 아닙니다.
미국 국채와 비교하면 예전같은 희소 프리미엄을 받지 못하고 있습니다.
특히 중장기에서는 그 변화가 꽤 선명합니다.
그래서 이제 시장을 볼 때는 질문을 둘로 나눠야 합니다.
달러는 강한가? 그리고 미국 국채는 정말 가장 특별한가?
예전에는 이 두 질문에 비슷한 답이 나왔습니다.
하지만 최근에는 아닙니다.
이 차이를 이해하면 미국 금리도 안전자산도 달러 패권도 훨씬 더 정확하게 읽을 수 있습니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.